the general feeling amongst business for
the last hundred years is that we need
to quantize space-time just as we
quantize every other field but
reconciling gravity with quantum theory
is one of the great challenges of
physics thus far we've been hopelessly
unsuccessful and so I think we're at a
point where we ought to really question
whether this drive and this challenge to
quantize gravity whether that really was
the right thing to do thank you
my name is Jonathan oppenheim I'm a
physicist at University College London
and myself and my students have proposed
a theory of gravity where matter remains
Quantum but somehow gravity is treated
classically
it's an attempt to reconcile the fact
that our current theory of gravity which
is general relativity is inconsistent
with quantum mechanics in physics we
have these two Frameworks quantum
mechanics and classical mechanics all
the particles in all the fields and
different forces and electromagnetism
and all that we know in nature that
we've discovered they all obey quantum
theory but quantum theory doesn't
describe gravity
our theory of gravity's general
relativity discovered by Einstein and it
is a theory of space-time so it tells us
that space time bends and it is not a
quantum theory at all the general
feeling amongst physicists for the last
100 years is that gravity is a force
just like any other force and therefore
should be quantized just like every
other force and fit into the framework
of quantum theory
but gravity is different
[Music]
gravity is very simple in some ways that
almost all of gravity is just that
clocks run at different speeds in
different places
that amazingly gives you the curvature
of space-time gravity is very much about
the arena or the background in which
matter moves so you have this quantized
matter which evolves in time and moves
in space and this background space time
appears to be a necessary part of how we
describe quantum theory
so let's say you believe that we should
quantize space-time what we're doing is
we're quantizing how fast clocks run and
it turns out if you try and quantize
that you're essentially quantizing the
speed of time and if you quantize the
speed of time what you find is that time
becomes Frozen
things don't evolve at all
so this is the immediate problem that
people grappled with when they were
trying to quantize gravity and we've I
think being stuck on that ever since
the black hole information Paradox or
annoyance or problem however you want to
describe it is probably one of the most
fascinating conundrums we have in
physics it somehow seems to hold the key
to the way to reconcile gravity and
quantum theory
it's a problem which comes about because
of Hawking's Discovery that black holes
appear to thermally radiate so if you
throw a known Quantum State a known item
into a black hole then the black hole
will just radiate it away thermally in a
way that seems to completely destroy the
information that was thrown into the
black hole
you believe in a fully quantum theory of
gravity you're pretty well compelled to
believe that information has to come out
of a black hole and therefore you have a
bit of a paradox but it's only a paradox
if you believe that physics somehow has
to be deterministic predicting
everything with certainty it's not a
paradox if you don't believe that
physics is deterministic if you believe
that there can be noise and
stochasticity and Randomness if you
believe that then it's not really a
paradox at all you throw in a known
state in the black hole and it comes out
random and that's just the way life is
and I think a lot of visitors are very
uncomfortable if there's a fundamental
stochasticity or Randomness
kilograms squared
seconds meters to the minus
the idea that we can consistently couple
Quantum systems and classical systems
has been around since the 90s and it was
exciting to me that these two Frameworks
somehow can be made to fit together its
base time is fundamentally the classical
background in which matter moves then
Things become easier in many different
ways so for example you now can have an
evolving space time the black hole
information Paradox no longer is a
paradox information can be destroyed if
the background space time is classical
and so what we you know myself and my
students were able to prove is that any
consistent theory of coupling between
classical degrees freedom and Quantum
degrees of freedom have to be
fundamentally stochastic any theory in
which gravity is fundamentally classical
has to have this Randomness and the
amount of Randomness you have to have is
a lot
okay 10 to the minus one upper bound and
then the lower bound is 10 to the minus
40. so a few years ago after um I'd
given a talk on the theory I got into a
discussion with color ravelli who's one
of the founders of loop one gravity and
as a result of that discussion we
formulated a bet with five thousand to
one odds
um on whether space-time is
fundamentally Quantum or not Jeff
Pennington who's a leading string theist
also joined in on the bet if I win I
will get 5 000 items from each of them
maybe some olive oil or a little drum of
whiskey maybe a packet of crisps and so
what I like about the bets is that they
force us to first of all make the BET
precise in a way that can be tested
experimentally because I think that's
important that we can test our beliefs
experimentally
we have these experiments that we're
proposing looking for Randomness in a
gravitational field which are I would
say an indirect test of a quantum theory
of gravity in that there may be more of
a test of a classical theory of gravity
but of course if you don't find
Randomness and noise in the
gravitational field then you can rule
out a classical theory of gravity
so we measure the gravitational field
say produced by one kilogram mass and we
can measure how much noise there is in a
Precision test of gravity
and then we can go out and we can
measure how long we can put a massive
object in superposition so you imagine a
gold atom for example and those two
experiments squeeze any theory in which
gravity is treated fundamentally
classically it squeezes it from two
directions we're all really struggling
to solve this problem we've been
struggling for 100 years and so those
experiments will determine the outcome
laughs
[Music]